give me some okra and some fried red
snapper and girl you know I want some
chitlins all right here
y'all got ham hocks
that was well that's what I want I want
to play the ham hocks deep fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet
I want some pig feet and four pounds of
grits and oh oh
you know
[Music]
Drew come forward
a chef this is a chicken quiche with
cremini mushrooms baby spinach and feta
cheese
[Music]
unbelievable
Ultra I have a huge problem with this
dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
thank you chef
because if you had Drew then I would
know how good you are at cooking food
that's bad
I'm sorry Chef when I say bad I'm a
Michael Jackson Bad
thank you Chef you know how we look
really really bad at the end of his life
I'm sorry I don't know if you like the
dish or not you don't know if I like the
dish or not well let's put it this way
Pat your [__] knives get out you're
off the show
sorry sure
because
you should be working in the finest
restaurant in the world
thank you Chef just not any world that I
live in
sorry because frankly it drew I'm
jealous of you thank you sure and your
ability to not give a [__] about what
you cook this
is not fit for human consumption no this
should be eaten by a higher life form
with a more complex palette but also an
altruistic drive to save Humanity from
dishes like this joking not you just
have to die
so you won't have to endure a life in
which you will never exceed what you
have achieved here today
thank you Sean
[Music]
in conclusion
you hungry
yeah man
um what you want uh
Pizza Chinese
[Music]
kill that noise man
I got a Ratatouille
[Music]
that's a rap dude all right ain't got
some Rider too y'all
hey Ratatouille go make my man a
sandwich yes as soon as you got
[Music]
what the son you gotta rat up in your
house
what does me
I don't know what to say man
I got a Ratatouille man he a chef just
like in all the movies man no no right
hey there's only
there's only one movie Levi all right
and he's not a Ratatouille he's a rat
and his name is Remy potato potato I got
myself so Ratatouille that's all I know
order up damn come on Levi
foreign
[Music]
look at this thing man you see it got
bite marks all over it
any good Chef has to taste his creation
that's rats
on the sandwich
didn't make a sandwich though oh hell no
I'm out my dude you need help
oh well Ratatouille another negative
review
maybe you wanted Charlotte's Web
[Music]
there he is hey
here's the deal 100 grass-fed Japanese
Kobe beef 35 a pound that's what I'm
talking about all right let's Grill
these little homies up
right all right oh is that ground chuck
man I have no offense I ain't trying to
talk about Bentley next to your Toyota
come on man oh you just putting them
right next to the Frozen pan yeah all
right relax man I'm gonna cook them good
okay all right so uh how's Teresa doing
she's good she's good she said she
couldn't be here you know she's got a
closing today you want to flash cook
those because they're real lean you know
they're grass fed so you just want to
probably flip them right right now
hey who wants cheese on their burger
nobody nobody nobody wants cheese
anybody want a double burger no nobody
wants a double burger We're Not Gonna
double that's like putting a diamond
ring on a pig off I'm stopping the grass
these cows ain't cost more than this
house all right no double Burgers hey
what the hell you may as well just poop
on that what you just ketchup raped my
Kobe Burger this was a mistake this no
no no no oh no no no no no no no no no
see this meat came all the way over here
from the Pacific Ocean by my boat
because the air pressure
wouldn't ruin any Integrity give me that
you are not working now brother
it's 126. oh this little mother 126
000.
y'all not worthy
did he take my dog
hello thanks for calling Mario's Pizza
this is Carlos speaking
we would like a large pie with a
pepperoni pineapple and cheesy crust
large pepperoni with pineapple and
cheesy crusts we would also like a large
pie with bacon pineapple and cheesy
crust large bacon pineapple with cheesy
crust okay is that going to complete
your order sir you know what let me
gauge the room uh guys we're gonna want
another Pizza let me just who's hungry
show her hands let me see them one two
three keep them up four five six uh
having a party
yep pretty big one too come on guys keep
them up Hugo summer hands food you know
what let's play it safe let's get
another pie
all right
um oh you guys are gonna need cheesy
crust on the third good question I'll
gauge the room hey guys do we want
cheesy crust on the third okay yeesh
that is a resounding yes for cheesy
crust on the third Claire says you read
her mind
I like that name it's a good one oh also
um a boy Andy over here is saying you
have something called chicken poppers is
she cute uh who's that and what now
Claire oh
her body's like a four anyway we would
also how
let's just say she's kind of a big girl
that's all good that's all superficial
man I like Claire for what's inside I
don't even know Claire
I feel like I do know Claire man
put me on the phone with her
uh
you don't need to speak to Claire no I
do
foreign
I
sir oh sorry I I didn't mean to get in
between you guys no
quite all right it was a while ago
before she blimped up
my current girlfriends live
Body Tan face tan
but anyway Claire yeah I hit that
sexually
and uh as did my boy Hugh go hell even
Bubba got some of that so just wanted
you to know used Goods used Goods so you
wouldn't care if I asked her out
well
let me do it for you hey Claire this guy
from The Pizza Place wants to date you
too poor all right I'll let him down
tell her
the no I'm not a rich man
but I'm a good man tell her Claire I
believe in destiny
and I believe that we've always known
that our soul mate was out there the
moment that we had that unspoken
connection about the cheesy crust I
realized that you were always the one
because and I know this sounds corny
but that moment
was just like
simple
wow you really do care about Claire
I do
oh my God Claire just got shot what no
oh it just came through the window it
was a
boy's down she's dead she's dead I'm
calling the cops she's dead
Chinese it is so glad we could bring
this project to this neighborhood it's
so rich in history yeah I grew up in a
neighborhood like this oh yeah I grew up
in a neighborhood exactly like this
all right welcome to Mama sugar bags
y'all ready to order yeah yeah can I
have a chicken fried steak with gravy
and a cola
I will have the baked beef short ribs
with color ings and throw down some of
that cornbread all right babe
you know what
hold up a second I'm also going to have
some of the collard greens and cornbread
as well but hook a brother up with some
of them hot links all right all right
you know what uh what am I trying to
front scratch all that give me some okra
and some fried red snapper and girl you
know I want some chitlins all right now
y'all got ham hocks
that was well that's what I want I want
to play the ham hocks deep fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet
I want some pig feet and four pounds of
grits and oh oh and you know what else
give me a little Dixie cup full of lard
all right I just remember what I want a
bowl of mosquitoes none of them tiny
ones either give me them big
[__] to find down at the swamp
assistant could you please hook a
brother up with a rusty bucket full of
fish heads wrapped in razor wire donkey
teeth donkey teeth straight out a
donkey's mouth you know what okay any
animal tooth will do I want you to stick
it in some honey glazed fry it with fat
back and serve it in an old tin coffee
can forget everything I said up to this
point right now bring me some dandelion
greens a cow hip and a dog face wrap
that whole mess in an old Ebony magazine
and serve it to me in a shoe box okay I
want to platter of stork ankles an old
Cellar Door a possum spine and a human
foot
you want a human foot
mm-hmm
I got just one question for y'all
you want gravy on that sellado
oh definitely oh yeah yeah you got to
put gravy on there yeah without gravy
it's not food
that's really
[Music]